so i've got a very big number to show
you today used by natwest bank so that
you can send them your secret bank
details it starts 2 3 4 5 3 6 7 6
did you get that or do you want me to
repeat it
so this number that we are reading out
is
617 digits long all banks have similar
numbers when you want to send them your
credit card details this is not a secret
number in fact your computer will
download this number when it wants to
send your credit card details it's there
to find this is public so this code that
they use on the internet is called rsa
it's named after the three people who
came up with it which who were reversed
shamir adelman trying to show you how it
works please all right
imagine if you had a secret that you
wanted to send to the bank
so the bank provides you with a box and
it provides you with a key to lock the
box so you can put your secret inside
and you can lock it and then you can
send the secret to the bank that's good
isn't it
but the problem is if the bank is giving
everyone one of these boxes and a key
that goes with it then that means that
well one person could steal someone
else's box
and use the key to unlock it and read
their secrets that would be terrible we
can't do that
so what the banks do
same sort of idea but instead of giving
out keys they give out padlocks
so they give everyone a box
if you've got a secret put it inside the
box lock it not with a key but with a
padlock it goes click it snaps shut
once it's locked and snapped shut you
don't have the padlock key so you can't
reverse it you can't open it up so if
someone steals your box they don't have
the key either they've got a padlock
but they don't have the key to open the
padlock the only person that does is the
bank themselves and it's a way to send
secret messages without having to send
out the keys it's easy to lock the code
but it's hard to unlock the code first
of all i have to explain this with the
smallest example i can and then i'll
show you why we use that massive number
let's say you're the bank and you give
out two numbers they're public so
everyone can know them they're not
secret numbers i'm going to choose the
number three
and the number 10. the bank also has a
secret number
if there's bank secret number for now
you don't know what it is no one knows
where that is only the bank knows what
that secret number is i had a very bad
breakfast this morning so i'm going to
send the message bad chef the first
thing you do if you have a message like
that is to turn the letters into numbers
that's quite simple a's 1 b is 2 and z
is 26. simple stuff c is three
d is four now i'm going to turn it into
a code and i'm gonna use the number
three
now there are some codes that would just
add three
or some codes that would multiply by
three what we're going to do is raise to
the power 3. so we're going to cube
these numbers here let's do that so i
get 2 cubed which is 8
1 cubed which is 1. 5 cubed is 125
and
6 cubed 216. the final step
is to use the second number the number
10.
i'm going to divide by 10
and i'm going to look at the remainder
so if i take something like 512
when i divide by 10 there will be 51
tens and 2 left over so that's just two
five here one and four
and that's your code and that's what you
would send the bank or the person who's
going to decode this message has a
secret number now the secret number
is in this example it's going to be
3. there's a formula to work out the
secret number i'm going to gloss over
that for a second but i'm going to show
you what to do next to decode the
message this is my code i'll write it
out again i'm going to do the same thing
i did before
this time i'm going to use my secret
number it doesn't have to be the same as
3 but it just happens to be the same as
the 3 we used before but never mind it
doesn't have to be but i'm going to cube
again
so i cube these numbers we do like we
did before we divide by 10 and find the
remainder and then the decoder we'll
turn that into letters which is b
and he gets the message back again bad
chef now that's just a taste of how it
works that's the process that your
computer does every time you buy
something on amazon or ebay one of the
important numbers in this code was this
10.
now this 10 was made by multiplying two
prime numbers together two times five
are prime numbers multiplying together
and you get ten now that massive number
that i showed you that natwest uses is
the same idea it's two massive prime
numbers multiplied together that's what
it is if you want to work out the decode
key the secret key you need to know the
original prime numbers
now the only way a spy someone who wants
to break the code could work out the
original prime numbers is to take that
massive number
and factorize it turn it back break it
up into the original two prime numbers
this is really hard so hard that it's
impractical to break with modern
technology the massive number i showed
you
was a
bit
number that means it's about it's about
two to the power
2048. now
about a decade ago
we did manage to break
512 bit numbers we were able to take
that number and factorize it into its
original primes a few years ago a team
of academics managed to break a 768
bit
number it took this team of academics
with all their resources two years to
break a 768-bit
key
and they said
that
to break
what we used now which is about 1024
would take thousands of times longer but
given that given the speed of technology
they reckon that
this sort of code
1024 bit
could be broken within a few years they
said they said that a few years ago
so this should now start to be replaced
gmail still uses this but this should be
this should be replaced and as you can
see nat west have done that or the banks
have done that they are now using 2048
bit number which again would take
computers
and i mean even yeah proper with a
proper attack
big computers it would still take them
thousands of years to factorize that
number into its original prime numbers
now hidden in the details for this code
is a mathematical fact that was worked
out in the 17th century by pierre de
fermat he's famous for fermar's last
theorem well this was firmar's little
theory if i take a number a whole number
an integer any number call it x
i'm going to raise it to a power
and it's going to be a prime number so p
for prime
i'm going to raise it to a power and i'm
going to take away x
this
is a multiple
of p the prime number let me let me do
an example what i mean is if you took a
number like like four
and then i took a prime number like five
and then i take away four i would get
four to the power five
which is one thousand and twenty four
take away four
which is one thousand and twenty and
that is a multiple of five but that
would be guaranteed you're guaranteed to
have a multiple of five now you can
imagine that in the 17th century when
firmar came up with this fact that
people said well very nice mathematical
fact that
that's pretty useless and well what use
you gonna have for that
and then suddenly the internet comes
along and it's massively useful in fact
our whole modern world depends
on this fact
so to use this code the public key has
two numbers i've shown you the massively
long one that natwest uses the other
number that they need which is the power
that they that you have to raise
that is not as big that is 65
537.
quite a big number when you compare it
to the second number
it's it's small
if you're in the mood for even more
about banks and really big numbers then
check out my latest video from the
chemistry channel periodic videos where
we've been inside the bank of england
gold bullion vault where they have a
couple hundred billion pounds worth of
gold lying around that's not something
you see every day
the link is here on the screen and below
the video